[Music]
my name is ryuji [ __ ] I am the owner
so run a usually consist of fire company
- evening broth noodles flavor oil and
in topic that's the normal remainder 16
all over the country now and then we
started introducing the ultimate which
comes without the broth that I comes
with all the other components that makes
no more running and a mother needs to
mix two unique everything that honorable
and that creates very nice delicious
flavor all of America it's not always
eating for people here to cook the
noodle in a hot rod I try to do this in
motherhood in order to make ramen more
accessible and more friendly for other
people and in the country when you know
that we have to do a lot thicker than
noodles that you see in the rock regular
ramen when it's thicker it's easier to
mix and also they don't stick together
and then we make a family-style
ramen noodle which means master's side
ramen so that has really nice waviness
you actually keep some stuff on better
so we could ramen a modern ramen for
three minutes and that gives us a really
nice chewy out of the fixture so first
thing you're going to toss the noodles
with our original scallion ginger oil
and after that you're going to put the
topping that becomes part of the fraud
and an Atari and oil and then the
garnishing making this one use economy
the very not a common thing but it's a
very big part of the US culture and we
make our own bacon here so as soon as
you receive it you want to break the
eggs the entire sphere on e and then
noodles hot so while you're mixing which
becomes more like a carbonara that's the
process of a building emergency
I was born in Japan I scored a portugee
prefecture about two hours north of the
Tokyo ramen was not my favorite food
growing up I always refused the ramen
just didn't like I don't know remember
why my family was very surprised when I
quit my job and I forgot robbing
business under my name when I thought
about the diss potentials of the
monument I got so excited so I kind of
wanted to introduce smarter and more
like a California rule even in Japan why
I'm telling you to pay closing the
modern because it's a very very unique
approach